college football national championship
game coming up on Monday Alabama against
Clemson part four we had a little bit
tired of seeing this matchup it is the
two best teams by far in college
football plus Urban Meyer went out of
his college football coaching career
with a win or did he spring in P family
great college football writer over at
Dow who sports Pete joins me here on the
show Pete if you had to bet one year
salary on Urban Meyer coaching or not
coaching again what would you take it's
a good question Chris I would I would
probably bet it on coaching and it's all
hinging on health and that's obviously
more difficult variable to predict than
sort of the whims of human nature but
III do think he's since you were willing
to step away and I and I do think he has
had some significant health issues and
at a certain point I think he hit a
crossroads we're continuing to coach was
which you know diminishing or
diminishing in his own his own health
and long term so but look that will be
the single biggest question looming over
college football for the next two years
you know sooner swim coach loses a game
everyone's gonna link urban you know
it's just going to continue to linger
there and it'll be fascinating he's a
he's a you know like hall prolific
winners he's just a unbelievably driven
and competitive guy and typically when
when people who fit that profile walk
away and they're still young and it's
not good years and them make I think
Urban's 54 they end up coming back
you've covered her Meyer for a long time
you mentioned his health issues how
would you compare his health issues now
to the health issues that forced him to
step away and eventually come back we
left Florida
I don't know Chris I mean I went to
Syracuse I'm a doctor you know I don't
have x-rays like you can't just lean you
just be in me now well I just think
people unfairly like to ride at him
especially people who like cover the NBA
and oh and I really like know a lot of
you can't no I just think there's like
this under running citizen where like
the guy was sick man like the kind of
cyst in his brain you know and I just
think there's been
there's been an undercurrent of a
narrative of always loose game and he's
gonna quit and all that I just I just
think like look the guys they can has
health issues you know and I can't you
can't compare him you know I'm not look
I'm not doubting the health issues all
I'm wondering is if it's Boris if it's
more severe if it's like you know he
left Florida and the contention then was
that he was done you know if it's if
it's the same type of health issue if
being ill for the second time resonates
more with him and makes him more
concerned about going back because we
both know he's competitive fire it's
gonna make him tough to sit on the
sidelines for that long yes I don't I
don't argue with that at all and I think
that the variables that you know if that
it comes back that the variables that
will determine it will be would be based
on health and that's out of my that's
out of my threshold to to speculate on a
my very limited intellectual threshold
as you're well aware of eSpeed family
college football runner yahoo sports
it's kind of a jerk he joins us here on
the Dan Patrick show one last question
about Urban Meyer Pete what about USC
would that appeal the Urban Meyer I
don't know you know I I don't I don't
know I like on one of our bar
conversations it's now just carrying
over to the radio absolutely this is
what we do yes our friend Rob McClanahan
definitely listening visit laughing
right now look that is a job that could
open next year you know there's there's
no question about that they would owe
clay hell in like piles and piles and
piles of money and also his staff
because they're all are on longer deals
piles and piles and piles of money so
that would be that's maybe what
inhibited that job from opening last
time and it could again look that is
that is the very you know if USC starts
one and two I don't know their schedule
off top of my head like that will be one
of the defining narratives of the of the
early part of the next college football
season and you know just generally
speaking a coach like that isn't going
to go in good you know take the
Minnesota job right or the you know like
a middling job and I in a big conference
like someone who is one like that is
used to the spoils of a bigger place so
yeah but it will it will be it is never
it is never dull with Urban Meyer who
will
almost just as present off the sideline
is on it I feel so we're barreling
towards part 4 of this Alabama Clemson
rivalry and I dealt with this in
basketball Pete when everybody wondered
is Golden State versus Cleveland good
for the NBA is Alabama versus Clemson
again for the national championship good
for college football I think it's fun
believable for college football I think
anyone who thinks anything differently
like just doesn't want to watch a good
game like all this rivalry has given us
and the two title games have been epic
to them you know probably to the 10 best
college programs I've ever covered the
talent in the game is unbelievable I
think that too obviously is a favorite
to be the number one pick in the 2020
Draft with Dustin fields they'll
probably go 1-2 I would take two or
right now and I think Trevor Lawrence is
just a just a searing store will
probably be the number one pick in the
2021 Drive so you have and then you just
have the gobs of talent on both
defensive lines Clemson skillet
receivers unbelievable is the best full
set of Alabama receivers that save in
his hand they're just in terms of one to
four they're almost interchangeable I
just think anyone who's complaining
about another great game needs to find
something else to do because it's just
like these two have separated themselves
not by like a river but more like by a
large lake to the rest of the sport
right now and if you're complaining
about it you probably have a vested tie
to the rest of it because I just think
from a you know we want we always want
the best teams to play in the best
matchups and that's that's exactly what
this is I agree with you I do think
that's the the failures of the semi
final games in recent years to be all
that competitive I think that puts even
more of an emphasis on the need to
expand the playoffs maybe make it a
little more difficult for Alabama and
Clemson to get there if they get there
great they're the two best teams but I
don't know I mean the last couple of
years as I've seen these semi finals
largely be duds I'd like to see more of
these teams out there like to see UCF in
the mix I'd like to see one of those
teams that doesn't get in B at Ohio
State or somebody else get an
opportunity you didn't do you think that
creates even more of a need to expand
the playoffs most people
the narrative of the semi-finals don't
let shrink it was probably one of the
dumbest narratives that's come through
college yeah well I in here's the thing
like what what the what the playoff has
done is what one of the BCS did for all
its many many many many flaws is it
really engaged the whole country as a
national sport it took sort of a
fiercely regional sport and nationalized
it so if you're a USC fan you had a you
had an interest in West Virginia
Louisville on a Thursday night you know
it gave it gave like a connectivity like
the connective tissue you know to the
entire sport which I think overall
raised it now was still flawed and
needed to go but I really feel like when
you look back in college football
history that era one of the one of the
legacies of it will be that it did
energize the sport as a national product
much like the NFL and NBA or national
national products and so here's the
thing now that we're in the fifth
iteration of this this playoff Chris is
that it really hasn't been that national
like I'm sitting here in San Jose right
now and there's about as much excitement
for this as there is for like an adobe
conference I mean just nobody nobody
cares out here the pac-12 through a lot
of self-inflicted wounds and financial
issues is you know really teetering
towards the relevancy now that is
because there was a bad hire at USC UCLA
creator down or there probably on the
way back Washington has been able to
push through to an elite elite level
under Chris Peterson but if there's a
bit at stake I think it changes
everything you know I mean look who
would think Ohio State went the big 10
two years in a row with with really good
teams and make the playoffs so obviously
the big 10 is the Big Ten is nudged out
the big 12 made it back-to-back years
but early on there was you know they
were sort of the one who was worried I I
do just think generally if you follow
the money and opportunity you're gonna
you're gonna end up this thing's going
to end up growing and just that the
variable is time and ultimately this is
a television decision more than anything
else
obviously the conference commissioners
and some people at the CFP I was saying
it but you know there has to be you know
when you follow the money the results
usually come and I do think we'll get
there I the variable is time and it
doesn't does not right now feel imminent
you ever been to an Adobe conference
hmm quite a few they're real fascinating
I'm a big coder I don't know if you know
that I didn't know that before I let you
go you've seen a lot of good quarterback
on prospects come through college
football we've spent part of today
talking about Eli Manning and his future
in New York and Giants sitting there
with the sixth overall pick Dwight
Haskins is at least on some of the draft
boards right now looked at at the top
quarterback prospect how would you
compare Dwayne Haskins as an NFL
prospect to say some of the guys we've
seen in recent years yes so this overall
quarterback crop Chris is not as robust
as last year unless she was pretty good
crop you know Whitney I think was on my
side first round by first-round picks
with Lamar Jackson being final one and
he's certainly looked okay I think
Dwayne Haskins there's a little bit to
me a boom-or-bust feel to him he
obviously has arm Talent and you know
right around midseason when I started
calling around people were like this
kids definitely going there's just too
much raw talent there but the drawback
is we've only seen 14 sample sizes of
Dwayne assets now the last three games
were unbelievable right but if you go
back to Penn State the moment looked to
big firm he looked overwhelmed Road he
looked rattled he looked like you know a
young redshirt sophomore quarterback who
hadn't started a lot of games so you
know there's an old Bill Parcells saying
where he wanted a quarterback to have
started 30 games and to have won 23 and
now Dwayne to his credit has started now
14 games I guess and in 113 so look
that's a that's that's a he's had as
good of a singular season as a starter
you have I think I know felt people
really like Ryan day and that's the
reason why Justin fields is expected to
transfer there because you know he's
obviously gonna you know who's their
mobile quarterback prospect in the
country last year and he's you know he's
gonna he's gonna try to follow that
trail that that uh that Haskins has done
and really turning into an NFL
quarterback under day's tutelage but
there are some there are some unknowns
about Haskins he's young and he's
inexperienced and that is gonna make NFL
types who follow certain paradigms and
like to see certain things it's going to
make them a little uncomfortable but as
a pure thrower
I mean you flip on that Michigan film
there's there some wow
always good to talk to Pete you could be
a little nicer
next time I didn't leave Yahoo because
of you I mean it was a reason lecturing
me on being nice all time richest things
this may be the highlight of mm I'll
talk to you the bar Pete SP panel for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]